you know nothing goes together better
than Lego and star wars Wow unless of
course you're talking about Korean
barbecue and beer because that is the
bomb but anyway when we heard that a
massive Lego x-wing fighter had
descended upon New York's Times Square
we dropped everything to go check it out
I'm Chris Kohler and this is a special
edition of game life
stormtroopers Yoda's and hundreds of
young Padawans were on hand for the
public unveiling of a nearly 46 thousand
pound Lego Star Wars x-wing fighter but
before the crowds had their minds blown
by its awesomeness wired got a special
backstage sneak peek
behold the largest lego model ever built
anywhere 11 feet tall and 43 feet long
with a wingspan of 44 feet you had
better measured your parents basement
before you even think about building
this at home it is 42 times the size of
the normal x-wing fighter that you can
buy in stores thirty two master builders
spent seventeen thousand hours
assembling over five million bricks into
this one-to-one replica of one of the
most famous fighters in the galaxy and
of course there's a full-size r2 on hand
when it was time for the big reveal
the fans were dropping bricks the only
question now is how many bricks would it
take to build the full-scale Death Star
game on Lego